na's first valorant masters tournament
is done and we have our first
champion sentinels despite now having
the answer to whether tens and sens
could do it
we're left with even more questions like
what's next for sentinels can phase make
their playstyle
work against sentinels and what about
teams like envy and 100 thieves who
heading into this tournament just
expected more than what they got
this last tournament was a hell of a
ride and it's left us with even more to
discuss
so let's dive in
[Music]
two million subs is it impossible
no not with a community like this if
you're watching this video and you're
not already sub to the channel
please hit the subscribe button ring the
notification bell
and that way when the content is fresh
and hot and ready to consume
you will know immediately wow we asked
you last week
is tens even human but i have a
different question for you now
was this the greatest stand-in
performance in esports
ever i think it's definitely up there
because while i can think of stand-ins
that won an event with a roster in cs
like mike lele with nip for example
or incredible stand-in performances in
rainbow six none of them were the best
player
on their roster but this weekend tens
was the best player in the tournament
that you talked about keep an eye on
shazam there it is
he topped several categories like kd and
average combat score
and this performance was a massive part
of sentinel success
but another key takeaway from this event
is that the entire roster is actually
playing at a high level
sick and dapper had big individual
performances
shazam was obviously key to this whole
thing coming together
and zombs effectively played sacrifice
omen the entire tournament
having a sentinel's phase grand finals
after the 2-0
sentinels win in winners finals was also
great
because it clearly showed us that
sentinels are the best team in n.a right
now
so where does sentinels go from here
well the obvious first
question is a big one are they going to
sign tens
dapper had this to say on his twitch
stream tens
does want to play with us and he likes
playing with us
but who the f wouldn't we just won the
biggest event n a
so it's like obviously he's gonna say he
wants to play with us
if i won the biggest event and then this
guy
said nah i'm good i don't really like
playing with you guys
i don't think my ego could have took
that it's awesome that tens wants to
continue to play with sentinels and
as dapper pointed out that just makes
sense but the question is whether
sentinels are willing to pay for that
privilege with tenza's contract still in
the hands of cloud9
nothing is set in stone earlier this
month
hiko responded to questions about why
100 thieves
hadn't signed tens on his twitch stream
as somebody who's been on cloud9 and
knows
how the the esports politic works if you
think that
tens is getting off of cloud9 you are
sadly mistaken until his
his contract is up i don't want to get
into too much politics i don't want to
really air
the dirty laundry i have with cloud9 but
i mean if you're interested there was
there was you know
me there were some other cs players that
you might know in valor today that
you know has had similar
problems um if this was true on march
1st when heco said it then tenza's value
has likely
skyrocketed both in the eyes of cloud9
and any team looking to pick up a big
impact player
but why would c9 be unwilling to part
with tens if he's not playing for their
pro team
well i don't have a copy of his contract
and it's possible cloud9 just likes
having him around as a content creator
but here's a pretty big possible reason
with every passing stellar performance
this guy's value gets higher and higher
no matter what happens tens is getting
a bag at the end of this in a tweet on
monday
long time esports personality sir scoots
tweeted that he believed valorant player
salaries and buyouts
were already extremely high given the
limited opportunity so far
for orcs to find some returns when asked
he said that
he wasn't referring specifically to tens
but
in my opinion he could certainly be part
of this situation
look of course c9 understood that tens
was potentially
valuable to other teams and now the
entire scene
has proof of that but the question is
whether sentinels are willing
or even able to pay and while i'm sure
cloud9
could legally hold on to tenza's
contract until it expires
if that's what they want to do i
question whether or not that really
makes sense
i mean they could get some returns right
now whatever happens in the long run
this was a hell of a show
i personally hope that sentinels and c9
can work something out
because we really want to see how far
this roster can go
we should also check in with faze clan
as they emerge from this tournament as
the region's second
strongest team normally that's high
praise
and there is a lot that this roster
should be happy about
including a pair of big wins over team
envy that help cement their position in
n a
against everyone except sentinels this
team's
aggressive playstyle with baby bay
leading the way
seemed extremely effective but the
schmieg
as it's come to be known was stopped
dead in its tracks
by sends a couple players
good he sprays him down and sentinels
once again on a
finish the round and they're coming back
here four to five
the best team truly is having having an
answer for everything
you have an answer for everything like
you're straight chilling
that's what face needs
i hope they can find it i really do
phases coach trippy has five maps from
this tournament
all of them losses to pour over for
answers about
how they can deal with sentinels and i
have no doubt that when we see this
match up again
the shmiq will be even more
sophisticated than before
genji also had a notable performance at
this tournament as they finished third
and defeated both hundred thieves and
envy
to do so both mikhail and guimon were
top
5 for clutches at this tournament and
that gives his team an interesting path
forward
if they can learn to handle the shmeeg
they could find themselves moving up the
ranks pretty quickly
oh my word the cat and mouse right now
that is happening is absurd spike's
gonna be planted
the kl with the dark with a bit
gets food takes the double damage there
but he's gonna send the owl drone
through
hell has been identified shocked through
he gets him with the bose still out
i think it's fair to say that both
hundred thieves and team envy had a
disappointing tournament
envy at least made fourth earning
themselves 45 vct
points like gen g but for a team that
many expected to make finals it's
bittersweet
remember those points are what will
qualify teams for
champions at the end of the year and
it's basically like valorance version of
worlds
hundred thieves earned 20 vct points for
fifth
sixth and it will be interesting to see
how they handle that result
they added ethan earlier this month and
while
results in recent weeks have been
lackluster they're still stacked
deep with talent and experience if they
have the patience to get through this
rough patch
they still have the tools to get back to
consistent podium finishes
and with cs mines like hiko steel
and nitro on the roster it feels like
only a matter of time until they start
to figure out both
phase and sentinels na wasn't the only
region to hold the masters tournament
this weekend
in europe we saw the rise of ascend
previously known as
razer edge gaming despite the crowd
consistently expecting a different
result
ascend battled their way to the
championship past top teams like
nip fun plus phoenix and team heretics
cned earned tournament mvp as jet and
he was an absolute highlight machine
it's just keep it simple stupid it
should be just straight on in
cena there's no you know mincing of
words here this is very much to the
point he has made it to the back of
sight but look he's already found called
a mentor and that's a problem paul with
a spray through finds bone cold
see that feeling lonelier and lonelier
all on his lonesome now dives back in
that's one
that's two he needs more he gets four
three
go away
but of course you know i had my eyes on
bone cold
this guy is absolutely cracked and his
team puts them on
agents like brimstone omen and yeah
viper dangerous positions only that
sheriff beside him but they're cornered
and now timing is everything just keep
in mind
we'll be cresting it soon that's one
that's two the third
oh the third listen
if you're watching this there's a strong
chance you're an n.a
fan but european valor is incredible
right now too
hopefully we don't have to wait too long
for these two regions to clash
between tens and sends the shifting na
landscape
and ascends rise in europe there's so
much to talk about right now in valorant
did any players catch your eye that
you'd like to see us talk about or
maybe even talk to let us know in the
comments below
ah yes hello i'm here to see tens please
and then tens comes out and he's and and
he's like i brought you this bouquet
from the market and uh i was hoping
perhaps to play some valorant with you
later
if you would be so inclined